(somber music)
- Being a transgender person,
we battle so many fights
on our own inside.
And when you can conquer that
and be your authentic self,
there is nothing you can't fight and win.
I enlisted in the military
because my family came to America
as refugees from Iran.
And I wanted to give back to this country.
It feels so good, because
you're doing something
so much bigger than yourself.
I was assigned to a
unit here in California.
And they just totally
swarmed me with compassion,
but I felt a little scared at the time,
because I was a lesbian.
And I was scared that
people were going to know,
and how they were going to treat me,
because, ""Don't ask, don't
tell" had just been repealed.
I new that I was trans.
And I'm going to be really
cliche and say my entire life.
My experience transitioning
while in military has been
a really interesting one.
I started my hormone replacement
therapy when I was 23,
and that was about four years ago.
I went and I sat down,
and had a conversation with my commander.
And I was prepared to be discharged.
I was really, really emotional,
because I worked so hard
to be in the military.
I didn't want to just get kicked out.
And he pulls out this
counseling statement.
Just that I needed to keep up
with male grooming standards.
I just started crying,
because I was thinking I
was going to get kicked out.
And here I am having this
amazing chain of command
that was just so supportive.
For a lot of people in the military,
I was the first trans person
that they had ever met.
It was really awesome
to be able to sit down
and explain to them what was happening
and who I am and how I felt.
At the end of the day,
when we got our missions,
we put our minds together,
and we focused on what
needed to be done, done.
And that was it.
I do not think being transgender
affects somebody's ability
to be in the military and
to serve this country,
honorably and courageously.
As a matter of fact,
I think being transgender
is a positive thing
for the military, and for
this country as a whole.
Cisgender people, and allies,
and other transgender people,
what they can do to support
trans service members is
continue to talk about us.
Continue to talk about how great we are,
and how important we are
in strength and compassion
we bring to the military.
So there are a lot of transgender people
who have reached out to me on
social media and Instagram,
that have expressed this really
intense interest and passion
for wanting to serve in the military,
especially what's happening now.
My advice to them is don't stop.
If you want to serve in this military,
go get enlisted.
Go talk to a recruiter.
Be your authentic self.
Don't hide anything.
Don't lie, just be who you are,
and serve this country.
It's the one thing that I will always say,
whether you're cisgender,
whether you're trans, gay, lesbian.
It does not matter who you are.
Never compromise your authenticity
for the comfort of others.
(inspirational music)